[Musique]
bonsoir Aujourd'hui 20 mai 2015 nouvelle
édition du Journal de la rédaction voici
les principaux titres quelques semaines
après la mort d'un adolescent lors d'une
fusillade c'est une femme enceinte qui a
été touchée hier soir par une balle en
pleine rue attrape le point sur les
premiers éléments de l'enquête
l'Association nationale des élus locaux
d'opposition reçu à l'Élysée c'était
hier afin d'évoquer les difficultés
qu'il rencontre pour en parler Eddie
hait secrétaire général adjoint
conseiller régional d'Île-de-France
conseiller municipal à carrière
souspoissie c'est l'invité de cette
édition et puis le modem à la rencontre
des chefs d'entreprise il y a quelques
jours Marielle de Sarnez et Yan Verling
les deux chefs de fil du parti centriste
en Île-de-France étit à Versailles un
déplacement afin de préparer les
prochaines régionales ce mardi en fin
d'après-midi une femme enceinte a donc
été blessée par balle dans le dos alors
qu'elle regagnait son domicile au squir
Paul Verlin ses jours ne sont pas en
danger à un fait d'hiver qui intervient
après alors qu'il y a tout juste 3
semaines à peine un garçon de 14 ans a
été abattu en pleine rue les deux faits
ne sont pas liés assureent la police
judiciaire de Versailles qui est chargée
de l'enquête Catherine zulato Michel el
Mido et William
lelle squir Verlin attrape mardi fin
d'après-midi les enquêteurs accompagnés
de l'équipe cophile recherch tous les
indices qui pourrai les mettre sur la
piste du tireur à 17h une femme d'une
quarantaine d'années enceinte accompagné
de sa fille s'écroule sur la chaussée
elle vient d'être touchée à l'omoplate
par une balle de petit calibre ses jours
ne sont pas en danger ni ceux de
l'enfant qu'elle porte la femme a été
aussitôt transportée à l'hôpital 3
semaines après la mort de Moussa dans le
quartier c'est les mois je peur pour les
enfants pour les les filles pour les f
parce que moi j'ai a cinq filles un
garçon ça fait un an je suis déménagé
iess je me disais que bon là c'est c'est
meilleur espoir ici et ben je
m'attendais pas à ça et ça c'est c'est
chocant ah ça m'a surpris ouais drame
familial tir volontaire balle perdu
toutes les hypothèses sont soulevées ce
mardi soir à l'issue du conseil
municipal de trappe des élus
réagissaient à l'annonce de ce nouveau
fait divers sur la communeci il faut le
prendre évidemment très au sérieux parce
que c'est pas admissible qu'on puisse
vivre dans les rux de trappes de de
telle violence une série noir dans un
contexte
où et je je veux insister sur ce point
euh ce lors de ce premier trimestre
attrape tous leseffet de violence dans
tout ce qui est mesuré infraction lié au
cambriolage délinquence économique
euh violence faite aux personnes trafic
de stupéfiants les les les chiffres du
recul de la délinquence attrape sont
tous dans des pourcentages qui sont
autour de 20 % en terme de recul
maintenant la question qui se pose c'est
c'est toujours la même c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait malheureusement depuis 2
semaines 3 semaines il y a eu la marche
blanche et cetera mais rien n'a changé
sur le terrain les mêmes causes
produiront toujours les mêmes effets la
police municipale de trappe va toujours
être embryonnaire je rappelle qu'il y a
trois fois moins de policiers municipaux
à trappe que dans les villes voisines la
question de la vidéosurveillance va
rester tabou l'enquête a été confiée à
la police judiciaire de Versailles pour
l'heure une certitude il n'y a pas de
lien entre cette affaire et celle qui a
secoué la ville le 1er mai dernier
Moussa 14 ans avait été tué dans une
fusillade par des hommes cagoulés le
mode opératoire et le type d'armes
utilisé ne sont pas les
mêmes
et puis nous en parlions hier ces faux
policiers qui sur l'autoroute à 13
détroussai depuis quelques jours des
automobilistes le véhicule qu'ils
utilisaient a été retrouvé calciné cette
nuit à hauteur de poissie et il avait
été dérobbé lors d'un cambriolage le 11
mai à Villiers Saint-Frédéric politique
à présent avec la réception hier à
l'Élysée de l'Association nationale des
élus locaux d'opposition son secrétaire
général adjoint l'invité de cette
édition bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes également conseiller
régional d'Île-de-France PRG et
conseiller municipal la carrière
sous-poissie dans l'opposition
l'Association nationale des élus locaux
d'opposition qui a donc été reçu à
l'Élysée l'objectif de cette rencontre
rencontre c'est de défendre un petit peu
vos droits tout simplement oui
l'occasion avec Clay ripou sa présidente
et Jean-Luc trottignan conseiller
municipal de rambbourer vis président de
présenter la Elo l'Association nationale
des élus locaux d'opposition à un
conseiller du président afin de lui
rappeler le rôle joué par les élus
d'opposition dans les conseils
municipaux ils ont un rôle
de
important de contrepouvoir ils sont là
pour faire vivre la démocratie locale h
aelo donc votre association c'est une
association à politique on retrouve
toutes les tendances ou vous avez toutes
les tendances politiques c'est en dehors
des des partis politiques n'affilié à
aucun parti politique elle est
indépendante et c'est bien là sa force
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes vraiment
dans la défense et l'expression des
droits de l'opposition que nous
considérons comme étant les élus
d'opposition des garants de la
démocratie locale ils sont là pour faire
valoir les contrepouvoirs et quelles
sont les difficultés les plus
fréquemment rencontrées justement vous
qui siégez d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
maintenant dans l'opposition sur votre
commune après l'avoir dirigé quelles
sont les difficultés pour ça que je me
suis engagé dans C ça vous avez réalisé
les difficultés réaliser les difficultés
même si mon opposition lorsque j'étais
en en charge ne s'est jamais manifesté
sur une revendication de droit qu'elle
ne pouvait pas avoir les
principales demandes aujourd'hui des
élus d'opposition sont le droit à
l'information le droit à la
communication beaucoup d'élus
d'opposition sont privés de tribunes
dans les journaux municipaux c'est aussi
important pour d'obtenir une
généralisation des droits de
l'opposition aujourd'hui les petites
communes les élus dans les petites
communes 1000 habitants notamment ne
disposent pas de droits garantis par les
textes aujourd'hui donc la volonté de
généraliser les droits de l'opposition
et de faire valoir donc comme je vous
l'ai exppliqué tout à l'heure un droit à
la communication un droit à
l'information le droit de réunion à
travers la mise à disposition d'un local
d'opposition l'accès à des salles
municipales pour les associations
d'opposition puis aussi le droit à la
formation qui est souvent très entravé
très difficile d'accès aujourd'hui dans
les communes pour vous il y a un petit
peu un senti sen de dé démocratie
c'està-dire que les voix que vous avez
pu récupérer je parle pour vous mais
globalement pour les élus d'opposition
en tout cas ne sont pas ne sont pas
porté dans ces conseils municipaux elles
n'ont pas assez de de valeur même si ell
représent des habitants des gens qui ont
voté globalement soit il y a une
opposition et on reconnaît aux
minoritaire une fonction et un rôle et
dans ce cas ils sont là en tant que tel
soit c'est à considérer qu'une fois
battu vous n'avez plus de rôle vous
restez élu vous restez représentant
certes des électeurs qui vous ont
désigné mais quand vous êtes un
conseiller municipal d'une commune vous
êtes représentant de cette commune alors
il s'agit pas de demander euh simplement
de dire voilà si la majorité a des
cartes de visite l'opposition a des
droit des cartes de visite c'est pas du
tout le sujet l'objectif il est de
reconnaître un rôle particulier à cette
opposition qui est importante
aujourd'hui l'opposition municipale dans
la mesure où les collectivités local ont
de plus en plus de responsabilités et il
faut des contrepouvoirs c'est la raison
pour laquelle on a proposé àaliser la
mise en place d'un médiateur national
qui viendrait si vous voulez faire le
tampon entre l'exécutif municipal et
l'opposition quand il y a conflit parce
qu'aujourd'hui le seul recours c'est le
tribunal administratif vous parlez des
difficultés au sein des conseils
municipaux est-ce que c'est propre
uniquement au sein des conseils
municipaux est-ce que c'est moins vrai
ailleurs c'est moins vrai dans les
autres chambres comme le conseil
régional ou le Conseil départemental
puisque là vous êtes déjà au conseil
départemental vous êtes victorieux il y
a pas de perdant dans un conseil
départemental quand vous êtes élu dans
votre canton même si vous êtes dans
l'opposition à la majorité qui le gère
vous êtes élu de votre canton et quand
vous êtes au conseil régional vous
appartenez à un groupe politique à un
parti politique et dans ce cas-là vous
êtes accompagné aujourd'hui l'élu
municipal d' I est souvent démuni il a
souvent pas d'appui technique ou d'appui
politique parce qu'il faut pas oublier
qu'au-delà de l'engagement des uns ou
des autres la quasi majorité des élus
municipaux sont sans étiquette et donc
cela ne bénéficie pas d'appui
particulier et même il ne revient pas au
partis politiques de faire valoir je
dirais simplement la démocratie locale
l'élu doit pouvoir le faire de par son
statut d'élu création d'un statut mise
en place d'un médiateur c'est quelquesun
des proposition que vous avez porté hier
quel écho pour ces propositions un grand
intérêt du conseiller du président euh
aussi une découverte hein pour lui euh
de cette association il en il ignorait
l'existence je rappelle quand même c'est
la seule au niveau national qui est en
charge des élus locaux d'opposition
c'est la raison pour laquelle un
prochain rendez-vous est fixé pour le
mois de septembre avec l'ensemble du
bureau de façon à pouvoir à ce moment-là
poser clairement sur la table
l'évolution des demandes et voir comment
elle pourrait être mise en œuvre si ces
dernières étaient retenues il est clair
qu'un médiateur comme on le pose
aujourd'hui viendrait désengorger le
tribunal administratif qui est encombré
et viendrait permettre en fait aussi une
égalité de traitement parce
qu'aujourd'hui si vous attaquez le maire
en place dispose des moyens publics pour
se défendre et l'élu d'opposition est
souvent démuni et donc il faudrait
pouvoir rendre obligatoire le passage
par le médiateur pour une vraie équité
de traitement sur les moyens de à
disposition pour la justice donc ça
passerait par une évolution de la loi
faudraexouolution de la loi ou du code
général des collectivités territoriales
mais dans tous les cas il y a besoin de
simplifier tout cela et puis surtout de
pacifier les relations dans les conseils
municipaux parce que le citoyen il veut
que les affaires d'une commune
fonctionnent il est pas là pour assister
à la chicane politique ou de la cur
stérile et un élu d'opposition même s'il
est dans l'opposition participe à la vie
municipale concours au bien-être des
habitants et c'est important que tout
cela soit fait dans la sérénité le but
de l'association c'est aussi de de
décerner les bons et les mauvais points
les les mauvaises élèves les bons élèves
vous avez listé un petit peu les
difficultés rencontrer alors il y a
effectivement euh les les bonédanes et
et les marienes de la démocratie locale
enfin enfin pour faire pour faire vite
euh en sachant que les boninas ne sont
pas attribués en fonction d'une
appréciation subjective euh le bonetdane
de la démocratie locale enfin des élus
locaux d'opposition et décerné à un
maire qui se serait vu condamné au
tribunal administratif donc très
objectif et donc ça n'est pas lié à
simplement une une appréciation
subjective sur tel ou tel et tel ou tel
comportement donc c'est quelque chose
qui vient simplement rappeler je dirais
aux élus qu'ils ont aussi l'obligation à
faire respecter le droit la prochaine
étape donc cette prochaine réunion vous
avez mentionn Rion Mo septreélisé avec
des avec l'Association nationale des
élus locaux et nous nous avons très
prochainement un rendez-vous avec
l'association des maires d'île-de-fance
pour voir comment un partenariat
pourrait se nouer et nous souhaitons
aussi pouvoir rencontrer prochainement
l'Association des maires de France de
façon à ce que imaginons qu'un certain
nombre d'élus d'opposition dans une
commune souhaiterait adhérer à
l'association bah que la mairie puisse
prendre en charge cette adhésion comme
ça se fait quand vous adhérez à telle ou
telle association pour la commune donc
voilà une façon de rendre plus équitable
un certain nombre de choses dans le
fonctionnement municipal pour conclure
cet entretien j'ai profité de votre
présence en plateau pour parler régional
continue à parler politique politique à
gauche puisque vous êtes je l'ai précisé
tout à l'heure conseiller régional dans
la majorité jusqu'à présent de Jean-Paul
Huchon ce dernier qui ne sera pas
candidat puisque c'est le président de
l'Assemblée nationale Claude Bartelone
qui représentera le Parti socialiste
votre avis déjà sur ce choix et sur les
éventuelles négociations à venir avec le
PRG votre al président de la région
jean-puchon reste président jusqu'à la
fin de de l'année hein jusqu'au 6 et 13
et au 13 décembre on a de gros chantiers
comme le Pass Navigo à tarif unique à
mettre en place notamment ainsi que le
contrat de plan est à région pour
l'instant ce sont essentiellement des
affaires internes au partis socialistes
euh ce qui doit prév valoir maintenant
c'est le rassemblement de la gauche
parce qu'il nous faut conserver cette
région à gauche on a des raisons de
craindre si Madame pecrè prenait la
présidence de cette région donc je
dirais je n'ai pas d'appréciation
personnelle à apporter si ce n'est que
le bilan aujourd'hui de cette de ces 17
années de région à gauche sont aussi le
résultat de l'exercice politique d'un
homme fort qui était Jean-Paul Luchon et
d'un bilan d'une majorité de gauche
rassemblée autour de lui autour des
objectifs politiques que nous nous
étions fixés donc c'est à mettre à son
crédit maintenant une nouvelle séquence
personnellement d'être présent sur cette
liste dès le premier tour moi j'ai la
volonté de repartir aux élections
régionales pour poursuivre le travail
engagé maintenant les conditions du
rassemblement le Parti socialiste si
nous devons nous allier à ce dernier il
doit les créer il doit favoriser le
rassemblement nous nous attendons qu'une
fois Claude Bartelone a investi
officiellement à partir du 28 mai que
des contacts soient pris c'est à lui de
prendre contact avec ses partenaires de
gauche le rassemblement oui au service
des franiliens bien sûr et avec
l'ensemble des composantes et notamment
le Parti radical de gauche je vous
propose un micro trottoir dans quelques
semaines il y aura le congrès socialiste
de Poitier les 5 6 et 7 juin le PS va
déterminer ses grandes orientations
politiques renouveler l'ensemble de ces
instances il y a plusieurs tendances
vous le savez faut-il plus de social
c'est la question que nous sommes allés
vous poser social parce que je trouve
que le libéralisme aujourd'hui n'appte
pas forcément que du bien on voit le
taux du chômage on voit tout ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui donc une gauche moins
libérale mais bon le libéralisme fait
partie aussi de l'économie et on a
besoin d'É donc c'est difficile comme
réponse une gauche plus sociale moi je
suis assez déçu perso du de l'action
gouvernementale donc c'est en tant que
écteur de gauche je m'attendais à mieux
plus social puisque c'est les valeur que
j'ai depuis toujours c'est c'est une
question compliquée parce que en même
temps on comprend les enjeux libéraux
qui qui sont en place on comprend toute
la dynamique de la mondialisation donc
on bon je dirais plus plus social parce
que actuellement la gauche qui est au
pouvoir c'est une fausse c'est une
fausse gauche vous parliez du
rassemblement justement des conditions
nécessaires au rassemblement ça en fait
partie une gauche plus sociale moins
libérale en tout cas il y a débat au
sein du Parti socialiste je crois que
les les les congrès les université d'été
sont fait sont fait pour cela plus de
social moins de social je sais pas trop
où on fixe le curseur le principal c'est
que la gauche soit bien fidèle à ses
valeurs et qu'on ait un objectif en tête
celui de garantir l'accès emploi pour le
plus grand nombre de Français je crois
que cette promesse républicaine là la
gauche doit la tenir merci ed je
rappelle que vous étiez ce soir en
plateau pour parler de l'Association
nationale des élus locaux d'opposition
dont vous êtes le secrétaire général
adjoint on reste dans la politique mais
du côté des centristes à présent dans le
cadre de cette campagne pour les
élections régionales de chef de fil du
Mouvement Démocrate vont à la rencontre
des Franciliens ce lundi Marielle de
Sarnez Yan Verling ont rencontré à
Versailles les entrepreneurs pour parler
du développement économique Mélanie poet
William
l le candidat tête de liste pour pour le
Mouvement Démocrate n'est pas encore
connu mais les chefs de fil multiplient
les déplacements pour échanger autour de
thématique ce lundi c'était autour des
entreprises et du développement
économique nous on veut une région qui
soit au côté des entreprises qui les
aide 30 % du temps dans une entreprise
c'est un temps passé à faire des papiers
l'administratif la bureaucratie et bien
moi je pense que la région pourrait
faire ça par exemple à la place des
entrepreneurs et donc je suis là pour
nous sommes là Yan et moi pour les
écouter pour les entendre beaucoup de
petites et moyennes entreprises surtout
les petites entreprises ont des
difficultés à accéder au marchés publics
c'est des marchés énormees souvent et
nous on veut que ces entreprises
puissent y accéder donc on veut les
aider à pouvoir se rassembler se
regrouper pour répondre à ces marché
public parce qu'aujourd'hui il faut être
grand il faut être gros pour pouvoir
faire face à une administration trop
lourde dans les ivelines ce sont plus de
48000 établissements qui ont été
recensés au premier trimestre 2015 plus
de 35000 entreprises ont été créé en
île-defance le développement économique
est l'une des compétences du Conseil
régional je trouve que voilà justement
il y a trop d'information partout et on
a du mal des questions simples donc on
aimerait avoir un guichet unique où on
répond des questions emploi et
entrepreneuriat génération
subvention les modalités l'URSAF tout ça
et en fait c'est diffus partout et c'est
je pense que c'est très difficile
aujourd'hui pour les gens de se
retrouver c'est savoir quels sont les
soutiens dont peut bénéficier une une
entreprise au niveau de la région tout
simplement c'est diffuser de
l'information passer l'information
euh parce que un chef d'entreprise
s'occupe de son entreprise c'est pas un
chasseur de subvention ou d'autre chose
l'île-de-fance représente 29 % du PIB de
l'Hexagone un tout autre sujet à présent
la finale nationale des Olympiades des
sciences de l'ingénieur qui s'est
déroulé aujourd'hui au Technocentre
Renault c'est à guilloncour une
compétition qui a réuni une soixantaine
d'équipes de lycéen de de toute la
France le reportage est signé Michel
elmidoro et William l des drones des
robots une main artificielle qui
fonctionne à distance avec des
contractions musculaires bienvenue à la
finale nationale des Olympiades de
sciences de l'ingénieur cette 6e édition
est organisée pour la première fois dans
l'entre du technoocenteno à guencour 60
équipes composé chacune de qu à 5
lycéens ont été sélectionnées pour ce
grand rendez-vous ce sont les meilleurs
lycéens de France s lycéens suivent un
enseignement de sciences de l'ingénieur
aujourd'hui nous avons les 300 meilleurs
lycéens de France ils ont déjà été
présélectionnés dans des finales
académiques partout en France y compris
dans les départements de tremè chaque
année nous organisons cet événement donc
chaque année nous avons la possibilité
de montrer qu'en France nos jeunes ils
ont du talent parmi les jeunes présents
sur l'événement retrouve Mathieu
Tournier et ses collaborateurs ses
lycéens originaires de Lyon ont inventé
le vol sans parachute donc ici l'avion
évoluant avec une vitesse dans ce sens
il suffit d'accé ér la personne dans le
sens inverse donc au départ la vitesse
de cet homme est comme celle de l'avion
dans ce sens ensuite en accélérant cette
personne la vitesse réduit se réduit
petit à petit pour à la sortie de la
soute avoir une vitesse horizontale
nulle il ne reste plus que la vitesse
verticale du à la hauteur de chute donc
ici Guillaume va appuyer sur les boutons
qui vont pouvoir de pouvoir libérer la
ventouse magnétique et à la libération
de du magnétisme de l'aventouse le la
planche et tout ce système sur le
chariot en translation va partir vers
l'avant d'
pre la musique était également à
l'honneur lors de cet événement avec le
GAN piano l'innovation fonctionne avec
des interrupteur installé sur le bout
des doigts un produit qui aurait
sûrement beaucoup plus à Bethoven ou à
debsy on a juste à s'imaginer un piano
devant soi on met le gant et on
joue
ces prodiges des algorithmes pourraient
intégrer les plus grands groupes
mondiaux dans quelques années et leurs
innovations pourrai être commercialisé
j'ai
vu un système qui permet de détecter les
chutes avant qu'elles ne se produisent
et nous qui cherchons à réduire les
accidents du travail dans nos
établissements c'est évidemment quelque
chose qui on peut creuser pour regarder
si on pourrait l'appliquer cette année
le premier prix a été attribué à la
prothèse de main robotisée fabriquée par
le lycée Sainte-Croix d'Orléan le grand
piano a lui terminé à la seconde place
du
classement le festival de canne qui se
poursuit nous vous proposons avec Radio
sensation de suivre les ivelinois qui
ont fait le déplacement ils sont
cinéphil réalisateur ou encore
exploitant ce soir Nicolas kirilovit va
la rencontre des directeurs des salles
d'élancour et de trappe la folie canoise
basson plein alors installez-vous bien
confortablement car nous allons vous
faire découvrir le festival comme si
vous y étiez ici il y a ceux qui
viennent travailler faire du business
rencontrer des producteurs ou des
réalisateurs choisir les films qui
seront ensuite projetés dans leur salle
ça c'est pour la partie travail il y a
ceux aussi venus uniquement arpenter les
dence Flor de la
Croisette Luc boan est directeur du ciné
des lancour après 3 ans d'absence il
revient ici sur la Croisette et la magie
opère toujours ça c'est rigolo ce que
j'aime à Cann c'est que c'est le grand
cirque du cinéma enfin c'est la fête du
cinéma mondial tout le monde est là la
petite exploitation la moyenne
exploitation parce que moi je je suis un
exploitant mais il y a aussi des
producteurs distributeurs tout le monde
se mélange des comédiens des gens qu'on
connaît des gens qu'on rencontre donc
c'est l'occasion à la fois de voir des
films parce que nous on vient surtout
pour travailler pour voir des films pour
pouvoir les programmer les défendre les
suivre après dans nos salles et puis
aussi rencontrer des gens des
opportunités pour monter des projets
travailler ensemble et cetera voilà
c'est ça can pu c'est la fête du cidéma
Mondial une fête à laquelle il faut
s'armer de patience pour aller voir un
film il est nécessaire parfois de s'y
prendre une à 2 heures avant la
projection avec en prime une longue file
d'attente faut savoir garder sa place Al
il y a aussi des fois des incivilités
tout à l'heure dans une file d'attente
des gens qui s'insultaient pour une
place de cinéma bon c'est quand même
c'est quand même ENF voilà on vient voir
des films quoi on fait pas la guerre
donc il y a vraiment des fois des des
des gens qui s'énervent qui s'excitent
qui sont prêt à tout pour passer essayer
de de gruger passer devant quelqu'un et
cetera et cetera bon tu rentres pas tu
rentres pas c'est le jeu voilà on est à
Cl on va pas pleurer non plus c'est
c'est un moment super agréable dans une
année professionnelle pour ceux qui
travaillent he voilà bien sûr et dans
les longues files d'attente en compagnie
des collègues on partage idées et points
de vue sur les films on narrête pas on
discute de ce qu'on a vu parce qu'on
voit pas tous la même chose on discute
de ce qu'on essaie de voir parce qu'on
verra pas tous la même chose on discute
des différentes comment dirais-je galère
qu'on a et cetera et puis oui on parle
des films forcément voilà c'est c'est
normal un autre exploitant évelinois a
fait le déplacement à Cann Gael Pinot
responsable et programmateur du cinéma
Le Grenier à C attrape lui aussi
enchaîne les projections toute la
journée et ce n'est pas toujours évident
d'avoir un avis sur un film alors c'est
très difficile de choisir puisqu'on voit
énormément de films on est c'est presque
on est presque gavé de film on les
enchaîne euh et et ce que ce qu'on
ressent sur le moment c'est pas
forcément c'est pas forcément net parce
qu'on les compare les uns aux autres et
c'est pas très facile par contre c'est
il faut les digérer et avec le recul il
y a il y a beaucoup de choses qui
reviennent et là on peut vraiment
réfléchir sur les films et les aimer là
si si tu me demandes le film qui m'a le
plus marqué c'est Mad Max j'ai vraiment
beaucoup aimé Mad
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Max pour une sal c'est pas forcément le
film que je vais le plus
programmer j'ai beaucoup aimé le Woody
Allen j'ai beaucoup aimé ce mod Allen
par rapport au précédent c'est vraiment
un film que j'ai j'ai apprécié et que je
programmerai avec grand plaisir j'ur
très envie de moner à mes
spectateurs pin comme be se fix des
objectif pendant le festival voir 4 à 5
films par jour qu'il soit de la
sélection officielle ou dans les
sélections parallèles Un Certain Regard
la Semaine de la Critique la Quinzaine
des réalisateurs des invitations qu'il
décroch grâce à une application les r et
là en fait on a tous les films qu'on a
demandé alors quand ça s'affiche en
rouge évidemment ça veut dire qu'on a
pas de place et quand ça s'affiche en
vert ça veut dire qu'on a une place
obtenue il va y avoir quelques places de
distribuer en plus donc on on va essayer
de on va essayer de les choper pour
aller voir le film à 11h30 coup de
chance pour nos ivelinois ils viennent
de décrocher des places pour aller voir
le dernier film de Gus
VC ça vaut le coup
d'attendre mais il faut se dépêcher le
le film commence dans 10 minutes Cann
c'est la fête du cinéma mais c'est
également la
course Nicolas kirilovit que l'on
retrouvera demain il vous donne
également rendez-vous chaque jour 9h30
13h30 sur Radio sensation 98.4 dans les
Yvelines pour encore plus de festival
autre festival alternatia ce sera les 6
et 7 juin à La Verrière un festival
tourné autour de l'environnement mais
pas seulement il y a également un volet
santé dans ce cadre dès ce jeudi au ciné
à H enc à 20h so projeté le film de
Jean-Paul Jaude nos enfants nous uson je
vous propose d'écouter jean-fançois
Créel l'un des organisateurs qui nous
explique l'objectif de cette projection
projection suivie d'un débat avec la
productrice du film alternativa santé
veut montrer qu'il y a des alternatives
au niveau de la
santé le film aborde l'alimentation et
de montrer que bah notre santé on va pas
tout le monde sait que nos amis chinois
la médecine chinoise passant par là que
la santé est forcément grand part une
grande partie liée à ce que l'on mange
donc le film aborde la place de
l'alimentation bah dans notre santé par
un exemple qui s'est passé dans une
ville du Sud où une ville a décidé de
passer ses cantines au bio et on voit
les petits croch-pieds qu'il a eu pour
mettre tout ça en place et le
réalisateur lui a fait ce film là parce
qu'il a eu aussi des problèmes de santé
il s'est rendu compte que tous les
cochonneries les produits chimiques et
on va pas en faire des tonnes
sont magnifiquement Pr présent dans nos
assiettes et c'est pas pour nous faire
du bien donc il a fait un film militant
sur cette expérience de cette ville du
Sud c'est la fin de ce journal
rendez-vous demain aux mêmes horaires
pour un nouveau point sur l'actualité
locale tout de suite sur TVfil kiosque
l'ebdomadaire de la
[Musique]
culture